le compte à rebours avant noël a débuté
chez les commerçants le rythme
s'accélère pour pouvoir répondre aux
commandes des clients chez ce caviste
implantée à voisins le bretonneux depuis
17 ans prépare les stocks en amont pour
anticiper ce dernier roche mois de
septembre je rentre déjà des produits
par rapport aux fêtes de fin d'année une
petite astuce aussi c'est que les
produits souvent les producteurs
augmentent leurs prix en prévision des
fêtes gens se rapprochent de lui
produire une chair donc nous on prend un
peu de marge de manoeuvre
on achète en amont de façon pour
proposer des produits à des prix qui
tient la route voire être soit pas
prohibitif
lewis qui les champagnes sont les best
seller de ces périodes de fêtes 2016
mais certains préfèrent les alcools
traditionnels j'ai pris un armagnac pour
mon père en fait c'est un fan bien faire
l'adéquation assez important de savoir
placer un bon vin et puis derrière sir
digestif c'est important à quelques
mètres dans cette boucherie les clients
sont trois fois plus nombreux qu'en
temps normal
les commandes sont passées généralement
quatre à cinq jours avant le repas du
réveillon et bien une poularde les fêtes
de noël nous sommes que quatre et donc
je profite de la bonne viande de se
boucher pour pour commander pour
répondre à cette demande les débouchés
de la structure n'hésitent pas à faire
des heures supplémentaires
c'est comme des journées longues mais
même le soir quand on ferme à 19h30 on
est resté veut travailler on fait
beaucoup de préparations maison beaucoup
de nos curés beaucoup de choses en
croûte et tout ça donc c'est fait maison
c'est très loin faire pas de répit non
plus pour les poissonniers les fêtes de
noël sont aussi un moment charnière pour
le secteur cette structure vie sinoise
réalise près de 30% de son chiffre
d'affaires annuel au mois de décembre
commence à chercher les produits genre
et de coquilles saint jacques les gens
s'entraînent beaucoup sur le sol tarifs
mais sinon c'est saint jacques sont mon
lot barre pour se réveiller en 2016 le
budget moyen pour un repas traditionnel
sur les 35 euros par convive
de quoi vous mettre l'eau à la bouche